Terry when you were doing a scene I
don't know if you had many scenes where
you had to but if you had to make eye
contact with marty Feldman how did you
do that my eyes and I have looked up
into hell
I didn't do it having scenes what they
might have did that how do I be normal
you had a charade see okay I did I yes
the only way to really hide for Marty
Feldman's to put your nose against his
never see you you never know where he
only looked out of the sides of his eyes
later I did a movie with Barney called
silent movie
we had a great wheelchair chase we were
chasing we could chase you tonight move
it we were chasing a porno in the
picture and and you know Dom was pretty
good at it I was with the three of us
Dom DeLuise Mel Brooks and marty Feldman
but marty was incapable of running
anything you know so well I would say
okay we would be in a building gone
would go I would go and you did crash
and I'd wait and I'd say why are you all
right I'm all right I'm all right yeah
I'm fine I'm fun then we go outside bang
dami okay I'm okay bail you I'm okay
Marty I'm all right laughs I'm all right
I'll be all right
he was you know I don't know Washington
I don't know what do you not know I you
know the only
you know they only does every the only
thing I used to say to two waitresses
he wants to egg sunny-side up put one
here and one there the only way I never
see them god bless him he was
good-natured he was spirited he gave us
the he gave us a hundred percent when he
had bad breath